[Music]
thank you
now it is uh as we've already mentioned
Holy Week and uh the cover of The
Spectator speaks to that it's our Easter
special with some beautiful Easter
lilies there on it
and the lead piece is about the fact
that it's been a decade now
of um Archbishop Welby being Archbishop
of Canterbury and Pope Francis being
pope of the Roman Catholic Church
um I'm joined Now by Dan Hitchens uh who
is the senior editor of first things and
Andrew Doyle who is a writer comedian
and TV presenter for GB news and also
the author of this excellent book the
new Puritans how the religion of social
justice captured the Western World
um Dan you've written this piece about
wellbe and Pope Francis
um and it's funny that they both became
leaders within days of each other within
eight days of each other I think back in
2013 and when they were as you say in
the piece when they were appointed when
elevated uh they were hailed as unifiers
that might sort of bring their churches
together and in fact as you spell out
quite clearly the opposite has happened
has it not
it has and well to start with um Justin
Welby being Archbishop of Canterbury is
notoriously uh the worst job in the
world because there are such Stark
divisions within the Church of England
um that is remarkable just this year how
contentious those divisions have become
so in February the Church of England's
Parliament the general Synod voted to
introduce blessings for same-sex couples
which for many people looks like a step
towards an accommodation with same-sex
marriage obviously a very very divisive
issue and the uh Evangelical Council who
represent the very important Evangelical
wing of so they feel compelled to resist
this that if it goes ahead they'll
declare that it's contrary to the
scriptures about as serious Acclaim as
you could make
internationally as well you have other
Anglican leaders who aren't part of the
Church of England but recognize the
Church of England as their mother Church
who've issued a joint statement saying
we can no longer see the Church of
England as a mother church or or give
Justin Welby a sort of special
preeminence as the leader Among Us
leaders
and then as well as these big statements
there are multiple things happening at
the local level where you have churches
in London for instance two of the best
known big thriving churches have said
that you must suspend their standard
payments to the Diocese of London
because they feel so out of sorts with
their Bishop who supported this change
of a big church in Oxford which has said
the bishop can't come to receive
communion here or preach here so these
are remarkable steps it's not just
disagreement not even the kind of very
sharp arguments we've seen but something
very close to a Breaking of unity
um and you know as you mentioned in your
intro 10 years ago Justin Welby was
hailed as the man who could unite the
different factions he was a conservative
but he understood liberals and uh you
know if anyone could bring peace to the
situation it was him so that's really
the puzzle with which the piece starts
is how have we gone from 10 years of
those very Rosy hopes to the current
extraordinarily divided situation and
just and just before we get on to Pope
Francis you do have this bit in the
piece where Welby has said he's
extremely joyfully celebratory about
same-sex blessings but he won't do them
himself which is a sort of amazing bit
of fence sitting is it not
yes and there was a a moment I think
last year where he said on the subject
of same-sex marriage more broadly uh
that he had a view but wouldn't express
it publicly
so this is his attempt to be a leader to
say you know I have to represent
um and speak to congregations with
vastly different views on this this is
my attempt to bring them together it was
a good encapsulation of his approach
before he became Archbishop just before
when he was asked
um
you know you have people who think that
having women Bishops is completely
impossible
within the Anglican Faith you have some
people who think it's absolutely
necessary otherwise we're not real
Christians how do you square the circle
and he said oh it's very simple it's a
circle with some sharp bits on it
which is a really good sound bite but
it's also sort of saying I don't know
how to make a statement that I think is
true and that applies to this situation
maybe we can ride it out and he hasn't
been able to to ride it out even with
his diplomatic and and communicatory
skills
and let's just uh quickly sum up uh the
problems with in Pope Francis
pontificate
um I mean he is uh he's seen as divisive
because he seems to pick fights with
almost everyone uh within the Catholic
Church does he not hmm
yes I think there's something even more
fundamental which is that uh Catholics
have enormous respect for the pope as a
teacher whose words carry enormous
weight and Pope Francis will make
statements which are extremely confusing
on really quite fundamental matters he
issued a document which was partly about
uh very serious questions about marriage
about the Eucharist the central
sacrament of the Christian Life
and it was very unclear what he was
getting at and some senior Cardinals
wrote him said could you clarify these
points
um and he didn't acknowledge the request
or he didn't want to meet them didn't
want to address it and they've been
probably dozens of examples where he's
acted in that way where people sort of
Look to Him for spiritual guidance and
he comes up with thoughts that could be
interrupted in any number of ways
um and I think there have also been
episodes where he's intervened in
communities particularly recently with
this Crackdown on the Latin Mass
um where basically it's now a lot harder
for communities who want to have the
Liturgy in that form to have it uh which
have deepened those those divisions once
again 10 years ago an enormous wave of
Hope a lot of press about uh how Pope
Francis could get Beyond these silly
divisions between Christians and get
down to what really mattered uh and it
turns out it's not that simple but
there's something much more serious in
these divisions than perhaps almost
anyone had understood at the time and I
think certainly these two leaders had
understood because that's been the story
of their leadership is it gradually
emerging
how contentious these issues is how
difficult it is to bring sides together
Andrew I'll bring you it let me wave
your book around you wrote this book the
new Puritans uh how the religions of
social justice captured the Western
world are you surprised to the extent to
which religion as in Europe's religion
Christianity main religion Christianity
uh has itself been captured by social
justice
this is one of the most surprising
things I mean we've all become very
accustomed to this new ideological
movement infecting any institution it
touches whether that's in uh the media
or the corporate world or the even the
Judiciary or the police or or the NHS
we've seen how it works it infects
everything it gets into the surprise has
been how readily uh it has been able to
unveil its way into a traditional
Christian movements I even spoke to an
Evangelical preacher from America from a
Baptist Community who's who was talking
about how uh various of his colleagues
are now um running sessions on
intersectional readings of the Bible so
even the most sort of uh fervent
traditionalist movements or branches of
Christianity don't seem to be immune uh
to this particular movement and I think
this is why it is kind of unprecedented
I mean Dan makes the very good point
that it's always been the case uh that
there has been a struggle between
conservative wings of various churches
and the more Progressive wings of
various churches and that's particularly
in the Anglican church because of course
uh various particularly in Africa a lot
of the Bishops in Africa are inherently
traditionalists and want to promote that
idea and are now considering obviously a
Schism
um and it's always been the case with
Catholicism as well but I think what is
new and what is different is that this
particular ideological movement is by
its nature intolerant I mean Dan says in
his article that progressivism has a
religious fervor of its own but I would
add to that that this is a this is
especially the case when you have a
regressive movement that Styles itself
as Progressive but is nothing of the
sort and that is what we're dealing with
here it isn't the sort of movement that
will Brook dissent so in terms of
squaring the circle I don't think it's I
don't think it's actually possible I
think it has to be one or the other and
do you think I mean the religion of
social justice is is intolerant as you
say and do you think that's where it
gets its strength from and that's why to
a certain extent if there is a battle
for Souls going on it's winning
it will win because it's scary because
you know it's practitioners have
developed this thing which we
colloquially call Council culture what
that really means is bullying what it
means is if you don't subscribe to our
views we'll ruin your life and they can
be very scary people
um so of course you end up with this
situation where the Archbishop Academy
is having to sort of please everyone
because it's absolutely terrifying to go
up against these kinds of activists who
have got made their way into the
Anglican Church as well
um I in terms of the Pope I suppose he
has a uh a slightly different situation
but at every successive Pope whenever
they contradict something a previous one
has said is in trouble because of the
notion of people infallibility so often
it comes down to fudging of the language
which is why you get this idea of
squaring a circle as as Dan has pointed
out
um but this the the movement is
impossible to resist in that respect
unless you are courageous unless you are
able to say no we have certain beliefs
that are not compatible with your world
view and remember that this ideology is
a movement that really is about the
negative nation of reality the negation
of of Truth uh it has all the Hallmarks
of a religion of its own you know it has
its own esoteric language it has its own
foundational holy texts such as those by
the likes of Judith Butler and Michelle
Foucault
um so you can't just expect it it
doesn't it doesn't blend well with other
institutions it takes them over it works
more like a virus and in that sense
um the the various churches the Catholic
church and the Anglican Church could
well do with it with a kind of
inoculation rather than this attempt to
fudge it and attempt to bring it in and
claim that it's compatible it absolutely
is not
well Dan as Andrew suggests that isn't
it a quite a big opportunity for the
Christian churches uh it to resist uh
the religion of social justice because
as you as you say in your piece you know
that the elements of Christianity that
thriving tend to be conservative ones
and and young people tend to be drawn
towards uh more conservative forms of
Christianity
um probably or possibly because uh it
offers an antidote to to this negation
of reality to this sort of uh total
post-modernism
um when it comes to Truth uh that
they're offered everywhere else
is definitely the story of our times the
divisions are sharpening in politics and
in fundamental questions like
what is the difference between men and
women uh on which
you know it's very hard to claim that
people will try to claim
um that you know the Christian tradition
can be reconciled with what is now
increasingly the fashionable view so I
think
that is um uh that is one area where you
can see uh that trying to unify
progressivism and Christianity is
probably not going to work there has to
be a confrontation at some point
um and as you say it people who've grown
up uh in the last 30 years I'll quite
likely to recognize that and I think
that's why you find it is often the
younger believers who are more
conservative sort of which can seem
paradoxical to people who remember the
60s but some like Kate Forbes the SMP
Leisure Canada as was who got in trouble
for her views on same-sex marriage and
premarital sex and so on you know he's
33 years old she's in some ways quite
representative that younger generation
of believers who are kind of
unembarrassed know where they stand and
definitely stand with a more traditional
conservative View and you mentioned this
fascinating thesis of Richard Rex the
Cambridge historian who says those were
three reformations the first was what is
God the second is what is church and the
one we're living through at the moment
is what is man or I suppose what is
woman uh might be the the current
question uh how is that how does that
apply to to what you're talking about in
terms of well-being and Francis
foreign
but in 2013 very few people realized how
big this crisis was there was a sense of
well we're Christians we all believe
that God is love uh we all believe in
helping the poor we all want to be
United
um maybe we can put on aside these uh
kind of arguments which aren't that
essential about sexuality and gender and
so on
um but actually those arguments are
about human nature and this is the
Richard Rex analysis you mentioned that
the history of Christianity has three
big crises in it one about the nature of
God when you have
um you know mobs storming the churches
of Bishops trying to assassinate them
because they've got the wrong view on
how many persons there are in the
Trinity the Reformation obviously
another big crisis over the nature of
the church
and we're now living through an upheaval
which is as big as those and could go on
for as long which is about what is it to
be a human being basically and we're a
long way from resolving that question or
resolving these these debates so I don't
think we should expect any Unity anytime
soon but Andrew where there is possible
uni where there are possible unities uh
is between strands of liberalism that
have for decades been viciously opposed
to to Christian teaching and seeing
Christianity is very backwards and
regressive and uh let's say
um the the Christian churches I mean
there's uh there's Mary Harrington
someone like that is an interesting
writer who writes about reactionary
feminism and that actually a lot of uh
liberals who are kind of being mugged by
wokery as it were are now
um finding forming alliances with with
Christians and with Christian thinking
on ideas of Truth and so on
well yes because we often forget that
the Christian churches in our
contemporary time have been liberalized
rather successfully I mean long gone are
the days where the the Catholic Church
taught that if you were you were gay you
should be burnt to the stake and you are
essentially evil and demonic you know in
the catechism it talks about yes it's an
intrinsic moral disorder but it is not
the case that someone who is inherently
attracted to members of their own sex is
evil that is accepted amongst Catholic
teaching as being a a state of nature
something that is part of their being it
is the act uh and of course the the
Catholic church has always taught that
any sex act outside of wedlock is sinful
anyway so it isn't a kind of anti-gay
thing and the church has liberalized an
attitudes have changed but what you have
now is a movement that sort of seizes
the mantle of liberalism and claims to
be Progressive and it's nothing of the
kind it's actually closer akin to the
kind of uh intolerant uh elements of
church teaching that the church has
moved Beyond and has left behind
um so that's where you're going to get
this this conflict fundamentally uh
modern day Christianity has at its heart
the notion of forgiveness and repentance
ideas which are completely alien to the
Contemporary religion of social justice
those are things that they don't believe
in they believe in uh cruelty and
viciousness as a means to coerce people
and to go along along with their world
view I cannot see how that could
possibly sit side by side with Christian
teaching plus the fact as you've
mentioned so many young people are
coming up and are attracted to the
traditionalism of the church that was
the whole appeal of of the both the
Church of England and the Catholic
church is it's rooted in Tradition and
and that is something that is going to
appeal more and more to young people are
going to react against I mean let's not
forget that the religion of social
justice is largely propagated by people
of my age uh by um Millennials and and
Gen X uh these people are old now
Millennials you know they're in their
40s right so younger people are going to
react against it and then you've also
got the the the the the
insurpassable obstacle I think that some
of the teachings of the religion of
social justice are just fund mentally at
odds with Christian teachings
particularly when it comes to gender
when the when you have this idea there
is a gendered soul that we all have that
is at odds with our body that cannot uh
possibly uh sit with Biblical teaching
it doesn't make any sense it's
incoherent and so I come back to this
point I just think
the reconciliation is impossible uh the
conflict you mentioned is coming uh and
it can't come too soon
and dad I mean I used to work at the
Catholic Herald which you edited
um uh and we used to do quite a little
stories on the humanism that were coming
together of anglicanism with Catholicism
to Bringing together the two churches
that's not really on anyone's priorities
at the moment within Christianity is it
because both the animal communion and
the Catholic Church are so busily
fighting each other
true to some extent but I think all the
things we're talking about mean you know
people discovering new enemies they also
discover new friendships so I do expect
to see more conversations and perhaps
more kind of unlikely alliances and
interesting agreements between
um uh Catholics and anglicans who you
know agree about the nature of marriage
even if they have
um very fundamental disagreements about
um you know other questions that the
Eucharist or the nature of authority in
the church and I think those
conversations are starting to happen so
this is yet another example of the
upheaval uh that we're living through
and that's got a long way to run yet
well Dan and Andrew I think we'll end it
there but a very happy Easter to both of
you
[Music]